yeah you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where net is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice my
co-host today here on the air kristy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling
author of the book business boutique we
are here to answer your questions about
your life and your money open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five two two five ron starts us off in
houston texas this hour
hey ron welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
man what's up
well i have a question me and my wife
for uh
one baby step six and uh we've we've got
a high risk investment
uh that's worth about 25 000 right now
and we're we're getting it to the point
where it's uncomfortable
uh where we want to sell the investment
and cash it out
and i i would like to spend about half
of it on a uh
a vehicle that i've always wanted and
she's uneasy about that just just
spending that amount of money on
something that's
uh you know completely a luxury and not
not necessary
uh so i was going to see if you could
weigh in and let us know what your
opinion is on it
well i'm an expert on my opinion chris
christie can weigh in also
that's fine the the thing that i have uh
found on is if it falls under the
heading of wisdom
it generally is a small ratio
toys that are a large ratio
in your life meaning they're a high
percentage of your income or they're a
high percentage of your net worth
is a toy you shouldn't do but one of the
reasons we work is to buy some toys and
there's nothing evil about having a toy
and so and that's what this is that's
what you're describing and you're
talking about spending twelve or
thirteen thousand dollars right
correct okay and what's your household
income
uh we made eighty thousand last year
okay and what are your other cars worth
uh my car my i've got an old pickup
truck and my wife's car they're worth
about 20 000 combined
okay well one of the rules of thumb we
use is uh you're debt-free everything
but your house and we want you to be
there the other rule of thumb we use is
don't buy things with motors or wheels
all combined that equal more than half
your annual income right
and so you're not doing that it hasn't
violated that you'd be at 32 and you
make 80. so you'd still be fine
uh what are you talking about buying
just curious uh
a bmw z4 coupe okay
all right cool so a little mid-life
crisis car that's fun
i like it i like it i've got one of
those i don't have that car but i like
i got a couple of mid-life crisis cars i
live in a perpetual midlife crisis
when it comes to cars that is so um
and um how much do you guys have in your
401k
uh i'm 33 years old and i've got just
over a hundred thousand
okay all right ron are you this are you
the
spender i am the spender see you know
one of the
reasons that we're in the position we're
in is because my wife is so frugal and
and she has a hard time spending money
on anything i i have to buy her things
most of the time because she wants to
spend it on herself
yeah i would guess that just because
like we we teach all the time a lot of
times in marriage there's a saver and a
spender my
husband is the saver i am the spender so
the conversation sounds a lot in our
household like the conversation you're
having regardless of what it is and
and the situation we're in but here's
here's a couple questions i ask him
whenever he is unsure about a purchase
because i will tell you he is usually
unsure about a purchase
he he he gives me the classic line that
draws me crazy
let me think about it that's a title oh
a week a week later let me think about
it he's untied
six months later i'm still thinking
about i'm like oh my goodness here's
some questions
i just asked him ron what are you
worried about what fears do you have
around this
what are your concerns and i give him an
opportunity to voice those concerns and
and sometimes they are things we can
address and talk through together
sometimes they're really valid and maybe
a blind spot i didn't see because i'm
such a spender and i'm like oh it's a
great idea
so that's what's so great about having
these conversations in your marriage
because you come to the best decision
together
but i would just say give her an
opportunity
to voice those concerns to talk through
those concerns to actually nail them
down it can't just be i don't know i'm
just scared let's look
what what are you worried about what are
what are your concerns what would what
would help you
feel better about this decision and that
type of thing and so um i think maybe
asking some of those questions giving
her a chance to answer
will allow her to feel more of a part of
the decision either way
and then you're kind of moving forward
together but i you know i just want to
encourage you if you open that door you
might be surprised at what she has to
say and it might lead to
y'all coming together on this that's a
good point because it might just let the
steam off
might let the air out of the problem but
you know so by ratios
what i'm referring to ron and for the
sake of all our listeners as well
i kind of ask myself when i'm dealing
with someone who's wealthy or someone
who's doing well financially you all are
doing well financially
if i put my that amount of money in your
situation in the middle of
the floor and i burned it
would it destroy my life would it mess
up my life would it set me back
five years would it set me back a year
would it would it would it do
damage to where i mean obviously we
don't want to be that wasteful that's
silly okay but
but the point is if you if the car
caught on fire the next day and burned
to the ground and you had no insurance
would you have
ruined your finances and your future or
seriously set them back
uh or would you just not notice you know
like i had a guy call me up one time
that was making six hundred thousand
dollars a year
and he was all worried about buying a
twenty thousand dollar harley
and i'm like dude you could drive it off
a cliff once a month and nobody would
care i mean you know
you're gonna be okay it does it's not
gonna affect because of the ratio to his
income you see what i'm saying
so that that's what you know and you're
this this would this is a big enough
ratio that you would feel it but it
wouldn't
mess your life up and so that tells me
it tells me it's a buy if i'm in your
shoes i'm buying the car okay so i got a
question for you dave on this because in
in
marriage you do typically have a saver
have a spender one of the things i've
noticed and i would say matt's not like
this matt is cautious but he
he will spend money on things that you
know that he likes what about those type
of people and i don't know that ron's
wife is like this but what about those
people that genuinely
don't like spending money they just
don't and so you've got this spouse
that's going but this but we have the
money but it's okay we've got this thing
and they just they can't they hate
spending money and so it's really hard
for them to ever say yes to a decision
because they hate letting go of it how
do you how do you help them
those savers open their hands a little
bit you know
rachel and i were talking about this a
little bit yesterday on the air with the
launch of her
know yourself know your money book
because she talks about the spender
versus the saver and she talks about the
seven tendencies and that's one of the
seven tendencies are you a saver or your
spender
and the thing that she so wisely points
out is if you
both neither one of those are bad it's
not bad to be a savior
but what is unhealthy is if either one
go to the extreme
and what you're talking about is a saver
that has gone to the extreme they
cannot get joy from the handling of
money in their finances they can never
get enough
to get a sense of joy into purchasing
something uh and usually what i
prescribe for them is
uh increased to generosity when you
start giving more
well it causes you to have more of a
sense of abundance
more of a sense of open heart i'm not i
don't have to have this for my security
i'm not damaging or ruining my life by
helping this person with this
thousand dollar gift or whatever it is
and when you start giving more
especially hand to
not not to vague organizations big big
buildings but to just say
this individual i'm gonna help this
single mom pay a light bill for a year
or something like that then that causes
you to
to become a little bit less freaked out
and you can move towards enjoyment of
money yourself
yeah because it also kind of gives you
permission to enjoy money right because
you're helping others yeah
so but you don't want to be too far on
either end of the spectrum it is toxic
when you do that
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show where we talk about your life and
your money open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five chris is in salt lake
city hi chris how can we help
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what time i really appreciate your time
so i had a question about paying off uh
upcoming medical bill because we're
expecting our first child
uh beginning of february and i've spent
hours calling around trying to get the
numbers on that and decide to go with an
hsa plan because it had the lowest max
out of pocket
or worst case scenario my wife and i
saved up money last year to pay off her
student loans
and the amount is probably about a
thousand dollars difference between
paying off the med medical bill the max
out-of-pocket for the family
and her student loans and so my question
is which one would you pay
and i know that um student loan
forgiveness is kind of a hot topic right
now and so
i would hate to pay the student loans
and then find out we get
10 000 reimbursed or uh we're given
and so right now the student loan is 12
900
the max out of pocket for the family
insurance would be 13
hundred and you're going to max it
yes everyone i've talked to said that
i'm gonna max out the
out of pocket for my wife and then for
our son
we'll be like two thousand dollars away
and so we were considering just maxing
it out for worst case scenario but also
my wife wanted to have a surgery get her
tonsils out
i needed a sinus surgery so we figured
this was the year to just
get that taken care of oh and that's all
in the 13.
after the thirteen thousand usually
labor and delivery is not thirteen
okay every i called different um doctors
and whatnot and asked what they charged
for delivery and added that all up
i'm sorry you have a baby due in
february
yes okay well here's the thing
the the uh regardless of the student
loan forgiveness issue that doesn't
enter into the equation for me
because i think it's so unlikely and
it'll be such a long time
before all that occurs that you're not
going to see that relief anytime
soon if you ever do see it so i want you
to pay your student loan
uh and i want you to pay your medical
bills which one would i pay first i pay
the medical bills first they're
immediately due
the student loan has terms to it medical
bills don't have terms
the only reason get people get payments
on medical bills is because they can't
pay the bill
it's due when they send it to you 100
and so you need to pay that bill or
you're in default
and they'll put you on payments but i
don't want you to get into default you
pay the whole bill
and so but right now you're just saving
up money until baby comes we're not
doing debt snowball we're not doing
anything except
living on a budget piling up cash and
when you get
these uh baby comes and these
miscellaneous small surgeries are done
then you um uh
you know you pay your bill pay your
medical bill and then you tear into that
student loan as soon as you can
okay easy enough easy enough
congratulations we appreciate you
congratulations that's awesome man
what a great way to start 2021. open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five abigail is in woo
if i push the right button she would be
abigail is in greenville south carolina
hi abigail welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um my husband passed away about a week
and a half ago
he i have four hundred thousand dollars
of life insurance coming in
and a hundred thousand dollars in my
death gratuity that i actually got today
um i have three kids i don't work i owe
about 255 thousand dollars in my house
with basically my equity and then about
25 000
in my car um i'm just trying to figure
out what to do with it to make it last
and be smart with it for my kids
my goodness i'm so sorry how old was he
thank you
um he was 32. oh no
so you said 400 000 in insurance and
a hundred thousand in what in a death
fraternity
it's from the military oh so he was
military
he was just there
okay um and and you live in greenville
south carolina was that where you
is that where you were um assigned by
the military
um here's our national guard he was our
creator for the guard so we kind of live
where we want to as long as we're some
of them in south carolina
i see okay so the reason i ask is is
this where you would stay necessarily
yeah this is where my family is um i
mean i could always move if i wanted to
but for right now um i'm in a new build
neighborhood so
can't really sell the house very easily
right this second um
so yeah i'm planning on staying here for
a little while
and you said you owe what on the home
255
255 and 25 on the car
oh baby girl i'm so sorry thank you
a week and a half huh so you got good
support around you obviously your family
you got a good church family you're in a
hope
yes yes i have all the support in the
world good
i'm sorry oh my goodness um
well what i tell folks to do is to try
to make as
few decisions as they can
especially the more major the decision
for the first
six months to a year because
um in the fog of grief i mean you're
still just
um uh
i mean you're you're still just trying
to get your head around this actually
happened
you know yeah absolutely and so it's not
if something happened to my wife i
wouldn't be thinking clearly a week and
a half later no one does
and so you're thinking pretty clearly
you are very articulate here on the air
it's
amazing how calm you are but the um
uh um
so i try to give people some space to
grieve to make better quality decisions
okay okay so if i woke up in your shoes
what would i do
probably six months from now i'm gonna
or so or a year from now i'm gonna pay
the house off but today i'm not
okay okay uh today i'd go ahead and pay
off the car
if you're going to keep it would you
sell it and keep his old car
or sell his old car no the the kids only
fit in my car so that's going to help
you to keep her
okay so yours is the keeper and we're
going to sell the other one
mean both the other cars are completely
paid off old cars
you know they don't really cost us
anything well they cost you insurance
and tags to sit there if you only got
one driver but that's not a big deal you
don't have to make that decision right
now either it's okay
but yeah i'd pay it off if you're going
to keep it i'd pay it off
and i i would set um obviously you've
got some
uh if these military are they covering
the funeral
um yeah they covered it and then his
parents paid the rest so i don't have
any of those expenses
my only thing is i don't work so if i'm
going to
you know i'm going to have to start
touching this money within the next
couple months
yeah and your
400 000 is not enough to not work
right right so you're going to have to
come up with a career plan too
long right and my goal is to my goal is
to get my master's degree
um and stay home with my kids until
they're all in school which
is like three years from now is possible
okay master's degree in what and why
um in counseling it's been something
that i've been passionate about for a
while and just kind of solidified the
decision
yeah okay
well 400 is not going to go very far um
right
it's um i don't want to be melodramatic
yeah pay off your car
park the 400 in a money market account
and set yourself on a really
tight household budget
uh because i don't think you've got
three years with 400 grand 400 grand
will produce about 40 000
a year max in income and you're not
going to have quite 400
after everything happens here so and uh
you can't live in perpetuation on that
and do the things you're talking about
doing so we're probably not going to pay
off the house is what we're saying
we're probably going to end up investing
this money and using it for
uh to get through this two to three
years and get your masters and then get
your income up
and once you get your income up to
survival level
um either before or after the masters
then i would talk about paying off the
house later but for now let's just
park this money but treat it like you
don't have any money
okay much i mean because if you get off
into grief spending
miss future counselor and you spend all
this money you're going to blow this
whole thing up
and so park it to the side and act like
it's not there after you pay off the car
live yourself on a real tight budget and
we're going to put you in ramsey plus
put you through financial peace
university to make sure you're taken
care of
because we always help widows here and
particularly widows in the military
oh my goodness hang on kelly i'll give
that to you free this is the dave ramsey
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at 825-5225
our best-selling devotional she is now
leading
through an instagram live every morning
it is 40 days long
it is called living true and uh you did
the first one this morning
yeah i'm walking them through each
section because as you know dave this is
organized by four sections
you need to know who god is who you are
where you are
and where you're going to get back to
you so it's a 40 day devotional
and i'm kicking off each section with
them early in the morning to have a
nice discussion and it's kind of like a
free online bible study so it's just a
fun way to start your day and start your
year
with scripture and getting back to
yourself so yeah it's been fun it's
amazing to see the
testimonies already coming in from how
this devo's helping people so i'm super
grateful
living true 40 days to get back to you
it is a bestseller
uh and uh the first devotional that
ramsey press has done
our publishing arm and uh very very
excited about its success this coming
tuesday we are doing our
largest ever live stream it's completely
free
it's called reset rachel cruz chris
hogan
me and craig groschel pastor craig
from lifechurch.tv we will be doing this
live from
oklahoma city from their stage at
lifechurch.tv
january the 12th at 7 p.m and uh spend
an evening with us
from 7 p.m on we're going to walk you
through how to
reset not only how to put together a
step-by-step game plan to win with your
money
because you need to reset after last
year right and uh but also
rachel's going to cover some of the know
yourself know your know your money no
your know yourself no your money
uh materials from her new book that just
launched yesterday and pastor craig will
be doing a talk on discipline which
all weaves together to help you reset
and get yourself going again
if you want to watch the event it is
completely free
you need to text the word reset
to 33 three 789
seven eight nine text reset if you're in
oklahoma city there's a handful of
tickets left
uh it's a very limited audience because
of spacing and so forth there
it's only twenty dollars but we do want
some folks there while we're doing the
talk
we'd love to have you just go to
daveramsey.com
events and you can make that part of
your evening if you're in that area for
this coming tuesday
and again we'd love to have you at all
of these
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two
five david is in grand rapids hi david
welcome to the dave ramsey show
well hi dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
well my wife and i are worried about
retirement
so we're trying to figure out how much
we need to put away
and uh where to put it
okay and we have a
household income of uh 80 to 90 000
a year we both have uh our 401s at 15
percent
and this year we just started a roth
good
so how old are you guys uh i'm 53 and my
wife is 50.
okay and how much is in there now so we
kind of
between the two of us um approximately
300 000.
good okay got a really good start okay
what's your what's your fear
you're not gonna have enough right okay
well we teach folks to invest and i
personally invest in four
types of growth stock mutual funds and i
put a fourth in each growth growth and
income
aggressive growth and international i'm
a little ahead of you i'm 16 but i've
been doing that
for most of my working life and
uh you know putting 15 away and then
later when everything was debt-free i
just max out everything that i'm allowed
to do whatever i'm allowed to do
roths and 401ks and hsas anything i can
put money into
keep the government's hands off of i do
and i put it all in those four types of
mutual funds
the stock market since it began has
averaged 11 percent
a little over 11 actually okay and so if
you're invested in decent mutual funds
you should be in that 10 to 12
range and so if you retired
and um you had a million dollars and you
wanted to pull off eight percent
while earning more than eight percent on
your money hopefully
uh that's what you would have been doing
all these years anyway
uh then that would be eighty thousand
dollars a year
okay if you're invested at that rate
if you're invested in what i'm talking
about uh
you can take your lump sum that you have
now and it will double
every seven years approximately
so seven years from today when you're 59
you'll have 600 seven years later when
you're 66
you'd have one two that's if you add
nothing else
would be awesome that's yeah so if you
if you work till 65 and you keep putting
in 15
you're probably gonna have two to three
million dollars if you're invested like
i'm talking about now if you're putting
it in a
bank ira making one percent then no
you're not going to do that
but i'm talking about making the 10 to
12 range the stock market is averaged
in decent mutual funds okay so you need
to align with that to hit those goals
but that 300 will double once and then
it'll double again
by 66 if you're 52.
that sounds wonderful yeah so you're on
track you don't have anything to wring
your hands about but you do need to
watch it be diligent
continue to do the investing and make
sure you're invested
in those types of things and if you're
not you may want to sit down with one of
our smart vester pros
uh you can click smart investor at
daveramsey.com these are the people we
recommend
i'm not they don't work for me i'm not
in the investing business
i personally use a smart vester pro to
help with my
retirement i'm sure you guys do too we
do and what's so interesting even in his
question
i hear this a lot whenever i'm hosting
the show with you dave is the
unknown is so scary to people as soon as
you laid that out for me like oh
well great okay it's like the confidence
goes up i can see how it's possible i
know what i need to do but sometimes
things that are technical difficult or
just even unknown can feel really
overwhelming and really scary
and that's why i love the smart vester
pros because they walk you through it
and show you exactly what you need to do
and show you the path and the numbers
or even something simple like chris
hogan's riq tool you plug in the numbers
and you see what you need to retire
whatever it is just being able to see it
immediately
helps you just okay okay i see what i
need to do
yeah it's i mean for me as a nerd it's
easy to understand but what you're
saying is numbers
when they're accurate can uh relieve
stress and give you hope
yeah yeah when you know what they are
i'm gonna go okay i have a hundred
thousand dollars in debt
i make a hundred and fifty thousand oh
wait a minute i could put fifty thousand
of that a year on it and i'd be
debt-free in two years those are numbers
i could be debt-free in two years when
you can see it you can do it that's why
we love giving people a plan but you
know even as you said that i thought
gosh i remember when i was in debt and i
remember
this was in my late twenties and i did
not i would pay my bills
but i never looked at it all at one time
if you would have asked me at that time
chrissy how much debt total you have us
i don't i don't know because i didn't
want to face it it was so overwhelming
and scary
but actually when i sat down and listed
out my debts it was like oh
okay i can handle this because now i
know it's not unknown anymore it doesn't
have that power
and over me and i'm able to see this is
what i need to do
to take control over it it's amazing
when you open the closet door and turn
the light on there's no monster in there
there's no monster in there you know we
all have the monster under the bed we
all have
might be a little gremlin might be a
mouse yeah but it's not a monster it's
not something that can't be
slain it can't be dealt with that's
going to eat you alive it's just
you can deal with it but it's uh you do
need to lay it out and do some
projections and again having some people
in your corner
like a smartvestor pro i mean
i teach this stuff and probably known
more than anybody in america for
teaching this stuff
and if i passed away today one of the
second or third phone calls sharon would
make would be to our smartvestor pro
because she's going to want to be
reassured again that she's okay
she's been reassured we've shown her the
numbers 26 000 times right
but she's gonna want it again right i
know that and so i've got that little
list of phone numbers here's who you
call
you know in the corner and then you call
yeah and then you call this and then you
call that right but i mean
and then the smart investor pro is gonna
be one right there because she's gonna
because if she can go that's right it's
gonna be okay yeah
and it gives you a sense of control when
you list out your debts you see before
when it was unknown they had control
over you but now you're like oh i have
control i see what it is i can tackle it
same thing with your
retirement goals when you list it out
it's like oh i've got control now i can
do something about this when people do
their every dollar budget when they jump
in ramsey plus
they have the same experience they go oh
wait a minute where's all their money
going that's right this is
this is silly i can do this that's right
and then you get this sense of power
like you got to raise
that's right yeah it's just being out of
control versus in control having
knowledge versus not having knowledge
having options versus not having options
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five matt
is with us in san antonio hi matt
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you dave and thank you christy
for uh taking my
my call sure what's up so um
the question is what a little background
i guess beforehand
uh my wife and i were on baby step two
we have about 35k left household income
right around 100.
with uh buying back my military time i
work for the federal government
currently
with uh so that equals about 12. i have
about nine years left and i could retire
from that
um my
i also own a business that i opened in
2016 and i
do that part-time obviously after uh
government work so my question is
actually
transitioning from a government job to
running my own business full-time
i don't know if i want to
finish out the nine years uh mainly
because of the work environment itself i
guess we could say
a politics behind it and then also
the commute's kind of pretty rough it's
about an hour both ways
um so with that
how much money should we have set aside
before
before making that transition and then
what
what is what other you know what are the
best practices or best steps to kind
of make that transition as smooth as
possible what's your business
dog training oh okay best job in the
world
what uh what is it what is it bringing
in right now
annually uh annually it brings in
right around 30 30 to 35
thousand dollars yes
okay and what do you make of the
government
i make uh 70. okay so your wife does not
work outside the home
yes sir what do you need to live on
uh right now we're living on about
well i guess like around like 75-ish
75-80
oh and you're in baby step two right you
said you you've got some debt yes yes
ma'am
that's right well i'll tell you i'll
tell you what's so
great about this uh side gig generation
starting a side hustle is you have an
opportunity to
grow this thing small and it's i mean
it's already doing well 30 000 a year
i think is what you said um you have
that opportunity to grow this thing
while still having the stability of your
full-time
job now one of the things that we tell
people all the time is you want to build
this thing up on the side
so much that it can support you now
because you're in baby step two
you know everything's bonus because
you're gonna pay off your debt faster
um but you're building this thing up so
that it can support you you don't wanna
make this
huge terrifying leap where you just hope
the business will support you now the
great news is you're
you know you're doing great like you're
already making a good stable amount of
money there
but i would continue to build this up to
where you're getting it to some of those
numbers you're talking about that you
need to live on
and then what's so great is it's the
next logical step it's not a terrifying
leap
um whenever you leave the government job
but if i'm you
you know matt i don't i don't want to do
something i don't want to do with a bad
commute for nine more years
i don't i want to really pour my life
into this business
to where it can make 70 100 or plus
get yourself out of debt and then you're
doing something you love to do
um you know full-time but it's one of
those things where you want to make sure
the money is actually there you don't
just hope it's going to be there
you want to build that business up so
much that it can support you
whenever you're ready to make that
transition yeah what christy and i
always say when we're talking with
small business owners and side hustle
folks is get the boat close enough to
the dock
so that you can step into it not leap
and hope you hit it yeah
and that's uh so what it amounts to is
you're you're on your way yeah
so in in your case i think uh if
i were in your shoes i would set a goal
that sounded like this
when i have three months in a row
of 4 500 or more
and i feel confident that that's going
to continue
does that put you in the high fifty
thousand dollar up to
close to sixty thousand dollars be fifty
five thousand dollars a year okay
which is less than you're making now but
so you didn't pull the boat all the way
to the dock you weren't making 75 when
you gave up a 70.
you don't need to do that but go ahead
and have a really troublesome
year because all you do is work between
your day job and the dog job
it's gonna feel like you're working two
full-time jobs because you are yeah for
a season
yeah for a season to get through but let
me ask you this dave so is your job
seasonal matt is it do you have like
really
dog training i don't know is it like way
busier in the summer and like falls way
off in the winter
to be to be uh honest with you like the
whole 14 to 16 hour days is yes it's
getting along i
actually am able to take off uh the
month of july to spend it with my kids
and then also
uh december so that's like you're not
even working those
those two months yeah well i i don't
want you to do this on a wing and a
prayer i want you to prove it to
yourself
and so if i were in your shoes i would
want three consecutive months or 4 500
and i really don't care if you're tired
when okay
because you're not gonna do this for
very long what we're trying to do what
we're trying to do is escape the
drudgery of the day job
but we don't want to do it in such a way
that we run out of the haunted house and
get hit by a car
right but i guess what i was trying to
bring up with the seasonal thing though
is i don't want you to base your
decision on three consecutive months of
4 500
in a really busy season and you've got a
really slow season coming up because
it's not indicative of what
you can expect we want you to plan based
on what you can expect
right but what he's saying is the only
reason he made it seasonal is because he
just took the time off yeah yeah
so one july and one december but you
know if i'm in your shoes i don't care
you pick the four months or the three
months i want to prove to myself and my
wife that i've
my family my kids that we can eat off
this thing
and uh you're not there yet 35 000
doesn't do it for me you're going to
take a pay cut of 65 percent
i don't think so to go from 100 to 35. i
don't think that's a good plan
uh but i but i would take that 36 you're
already making 3 000 man
i mean let's get that up 1500 more let's
increase that
and and prove to yourself some level of
stability and then give your notice
and go live your dream and then have a
plan for
training dog trainers so that you have a
whole
school going and you're making 300 grand
not 150.
i was going to say 1500 i mean that's
just one dog you have a dog for a month
it's about 1500 to have if they go send
them off you know
yes about 12 1500 at least here in
nashville it's up to two thousand
dollars you send a dog
for a month they stay with the trainer
for the month they come home trained
asked ayo he did something similar so
that's well
pays all kinds of stuff for stuff like
that get you one dog matt get your one
dog one more dog
one more dog that's all you're one dog
away man
if you're charging right if you're
charging right that's a whole other
subject
if you're charging right that is so
great
yeah i was on a pheasant hunt and that
guy's he trains up 15 or 20 dogs and
takes them
yes on the pheasant hunt and sells them
off and so he'll sell all those dogs for
i don't know you selling them for
anywhere from five to 15 grand a dog
but he had poured into him like that i
didn't have any idea what they charged
to do that those dogs could climb a tree
though they were unbelievable they did
everything
yeah they were amazing so well for busy
people that don't have time to train
them or take them once a week to
training like just send them off
bring them back when they're trained wow
wow
can you do that with kids i've got
three candidates i've got three
candidates in my household i'd like to
send off if that's the case please
the christmas is over all the fun's over
let's we're back to work
help me out oh
2 000 i'm so cheap i've never trained a
dog so i mean i've trained them but i
haven't
i haven't paid anybody to do it so i
didn't i've had dogs smarter than me but
that's a low bar
so oh my gosh yeah i think you're one
dog away per month per month
yeah so i i that's what i would do if i
were in your shoes matt i want to
get the boat a little closer to the dock
you're jumping and i'm afraid you're
going to get
one leg wet or you may miss the boat
completely i don't want you to
uh and so i want this thing to be a
thing where you did it without with
wisdom
uh without a ton of stress and you're
gonna be a little tired
between now and then but by the way when
you start a business you're always a
little tired i had two years of 16 hour
days and this puppy before i hardly even
made a living out of it
and that's a few years back i don't want
to do it again but i'm not afraid of
hard work and i haven't
not done what i'm telling you to do i
have done it it's a season
it's a season it's not forever and i
worked like i was unemployed this
i mean i worked like i was doing it
again during covet to try to keep
everything running
i was back in here again for a month and
a half two months at 16 hours so
just whatever you have to do to run a
business that's what you do
but usually those are ebb and flow it's
not forever it's for a period of time to
get there
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice christy
wright is ramsey personality co-host of
the day
you call in we'll talk about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two jerry is in phoenix hi jerry welcome
to the dave ramsey show
thank you mr ramsey thanks for taking my
call appreciate that
sure what's up so my wife and i have
been uh um
we've been listening to you for for a
while now and
we're able to pay off all of our debt uh
except our house
um we have um about four years best we
can
tell about four years before we get the
house off um
we've got a rollover ira
um it's in uh it's in mutual funds it's
260 000
in there we have 25 000 cash um
and again no debt uh except for the
house um
my question is this is it wise or
the negatives i guess of taking some of
that 260
and putting it into a roth ira
um what what should i do with that is
that
is that a legit thing to do or should i
leave it alone or start with new funds
and fund the law outside of that
my 260. uh second answer yes i would
fund everything from this point forward
in a roth
uh how old are you i'm 52 sir
52. okay yeah if you convert it
to grow tax-free from this point forward
and you pay the taxes without using some
of the money
to do that uh some of the money in the
ira to pay the taxes in other words if
you paid the taxes that it creates
outside of there so it's gonna be about
65 000 at some point
seventy thousand dollars something like
that uh
then that has the same mathematical
effect of having invested that much
more because now that 250 is going to
grow
100 tax-free from 52 on and it's going
to make mathematical sense
provided you plan to leave it alone
and you probably will leave it alone up
into your 60s and even your 70s is what
it sounds like or the vast majority of
it you won't take out you might take
some income off of it but
if you're going to cash the whole thing
in at age 59 and a half
it might not work but you shouldn't do
that you shouldn't be planning to do
that
so no no so what i would do is get the
house paid off and then i would convert
it with extra cash that you have
after the house is paid off but i
wouldn't convert it now you don't need a
65
tax bill where you're trying to pay off
your house
ah okay got it got it got it okay
okay very good i appreciate your help
sir thank you we appreciate you calling
in
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five caleb is in
daytona beach florida hi caleb how are
you
good how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
hey so um i was wondering
right now i'm putting 10 into my 403 b
through my employer and they match
um three and a half percent and they
gift six percent
nice effectively that's got 19.5
going in um but my question is
i can afford more because i'm in zero
debt right now i just paid off my car
good for you congratulations how old are
you
22 way to go okay what do you make
uh just under 50. okay
awesome good for you well done caleb
good job
well what we recommend is that you
you're debt-free
except your home and are debt-free even
without a home
and you're putting 15 percent of your
household income away
in your case you are not putting that
away you're only putting 10 percent away
so i would up that another 5
and you probably could just do a simple
roth ira
yourself do an individual ira that's a
roth
in some good mutual funds get in touch
with one of our smartvestor pros
they would thoroughly enjoy working with
a 22 year old as sharp as you
that's a great joy for them because they
know that they're going to turn you into
a millionaire because you got so much
time in front of you and you're so smart
you've done such a good job and so yeah
i i would i would probably do another
five percent of your income
into something and that's not going to
quite fill up an ira but even if you
wanted to completely fill up the ira you
could it's up to you you've got some
room right now
and do a roth ira in good mutual funds
good growth stock mutual funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international are the four
categories that we recommend hey way to
go man i'm proud of you
very much it's just amazing that he's
asking those questions at 22.
that's incredible i love it kevin's in
buffalo new york hi kevin welcome to the
dave ramsey show
thank you for taking my call i'm 55
years old i make 75 000
a year washing cars at my home
i have no debt except for rent i just
had a
newborn child so i don't have health
insurance for myself
and uh i'm just trying to i'm i'm away
from big brother i'm living off the land
really
so my advice i want my advice for you
uh what you recommend fires me setting
up
health insurance for my child and maybe
income for my trial my child as she can
soldier
oh what a good dad you're thinking on
your feet man good for you
well done thank you well done yeah the
number
one cause of bankruptcy in america
is not too much debt that's the number
two cause
number one cause is not having health
insurance and so i
immediately if this week if i were you
would get health insurance on you
and your family uh it's not a rip-off
and you can what's the way to make it
cheap kevin is the big deductible
and the big deductible is uh you know
you might do what's called an
hsa a health savings account plan a lot
of those have a five or a seven thousand
dollar deductible
which means the health insurance only
kicks in on big stuff it doesn't kick in
on little stuff
little stuff you're a hard worker you
can work your way through the little
stuff at five thousand dollar tank two
thousand dollar thing you can work your
way through that
but it's the five hundred thousand
dollar quadruple bypass with an icu
visit by you
that could break your family and so
that's the one you want covered that's
why you have health insurance and so
that's what i have
i have a large deductible i'm 60
large deductible health insurance plan
and it pays a hundred percent of
everything
after i hit the deductible and it's an
hsa plan
and you can check with uh go to an
insurance broker you can check them out
on our website
you want a broker that's somebody
that'll shop among a bunch of different
companies and get the best deal for you
in buffalo new york in your situation
and explain all of that to you but yeah
you need to get health insurance in
place immediately for you and the kids
and then you can set up a uh you know a
college fund if you want to start that
before i did that though i would make
sure you're out of debt you have your
emergency fund in place
and make sure you're investing for your
retirement because the
one of the best ways you can bless your
kids is not be a burden to them later
why do you think that some people are
scared of health insurance
like they feel like it's a rip-off you
know everybody i think all of us
secretly hate
all insurance people for sure it's not
fun i mean it's not even a secret
it's just we just hate it it's just like
we pay we pay we pay we pay we pay and
you know you're never gonna it's never
gonna work out
but you're buying the peace of mind of
that big event that's right that takes
you out
that's that's what you're covering but
generally we just hate it
and a guy like that that's off the grid
he really hates it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you america for your response to
rachel cruz's
new book came out yesterday know
yourself know your money
now one of the top sellers on amazon at
this moment her appearance on good
morning america this morning did not
hurt that
i'm sure and uh causing some sales to
happen they were very kind to us there
and uh good good mention and pushes to
the book thank you and
a good interview too by michael strand
does a great job
and um you know she's done a hundred and
some odd uh
pieces of media in the past 48 72 hours
so
she's all over the place in your city
and everywhere else check it out know
yourself
know your money you can of course get it
at daveramsey.com
uh we will know uh in a little over a
week
whether or not it is a number one seller
or not but we suspect it will be based
on the number of sales going out of here
and thank you for that we appreciate
that
it's a book that helps you understand
why you do what you do with money which
is very important to help you cope with
your spouse
why they do what they do and to help you
cope with yourself the person in your
mirror
is a bigger problem with your money than
the technical questions some of you ask
you get the person in your mirror under
control you can make it through most of
the technical stuff
speaking of which it is time to reset
last year many of you got the crud
scared out of you
no pun intended and uh you were like got
your wake-up call and you're thinking i
gotta get this money stuff straightened
out it's time for me to reset at the
first of the year here
so we're going to have a reset event
this coming tuesday night
and that's on the 12th at 7 p.m central
time
we'll be broadcasting a free did i
mention it's
free live stream from oklahoma city
at lifechurch.tv's campus rachel cruz
chris hogan me and pastor greg groschel
pastor of life church and uh all four of
us will be speaking
throughout the evening it begins at
seven o'clock it
is completely free and if you'd like to
view this free reset live stream and get
yourself on a track to get out of debt
uh to become wealthy to become
outrageously generous to get control
get yourself where you're not
susceptible to every big bad wolf that
comes along and huffs and puffs like a
pandemic
a lot of you if you had a big pile of
money and no debt last year would have
had a whole different year
and i'm not making fun of you and i'm
not shaming you but this is your chance
to reset
i've had a moment to reset a time or two
in my life and you know you got
some of you were kind of going along at
ish you were doing ramsey-ish
and this is your chance to reset text
the word reset
to 33789 and watch this free live stream
we'll get you started guys
we want to help you we want you to win
we want to show you how to win
text reset two three three seven
eight nine and speaking of which if you
go to daveramsey.com
reset ramsey plus has a free offer right
now
to go through financial peace university
get on the every dollar budgeting
program
and they've got a detailed step-by-step
little small steps you can take
not the baby steps but little small
steps you can take to start to win
immediately in the first 90 days you're
going to see a huge
change in the way you feel about money
and ramsey plus has a free trial going
right now
access to all of that at daveramsey.com
reset so a lot of different ways you can
reset another way you can reset
is christy wright as a best-selling
devotional out called living
true and it absolutely
you know this 40 day devotional she
started the doing live instagram for
free
yeah this morning a live bible study
yeah every morning
every morning for 40 days well it's it's
each section so i'm going every 10 days
to kick off this section
but what's so cool about it and you know
this dave as a writer you know
everything doesn't make it in here
you know it's like they edit it down
edit it down edit it down so it's fun
because when i go live i can share the
back story of the story or some
some scriptures that supplement and
complement the heart behind it and have
a really great discussion
where we talk about how you put this
into practice and what god's showing you
through this area
or that area and so we kicked it off
today with day one i'll be going live
again
in ten days to kick off section two
where we talk about who you are and what
god
says about you in his word and so it's
one of those things where it's like it
makes it a little bit more personal when
i'm able to lead them through it since
i'm the author so it's been fun
well and since you can put in all the
stuff we made you cut out that's right
that's right because
christy has a lot of words christie has
words
words are christie's thing listen my
first she does not come up
short on word count ever y'all listen my
first book business boutique
it would have been thick i don't think
they thought i could turn in the word
count i was like oh
challenge accepted let me turn and
double the work there you go
and then we had to go back and go this
is not a boutique christie this is a
freaking shopping mall we got to take it
back to boutique okay
it's all important it's all important
it's all matters
it's all my words fun fact for those of
you guys that have business boutique or
have seen it that's the reason for the
trim size that's the reason for the
larger trim size because dave was like
christy this can't be six inches thick
let's spread it out
the worst so it's not so overwhelming
this looks like a door stop we gotta fix
it
oh my gosh all right open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five heather
is in orlando
hi heather welcome to dave ramsey show
thank you um first off i want to say
y'all have been such a blessing in my
life
um i have i paid off 111 000
worth of debt i have a fully funded
emergency fund and i've been through
entre leadership
and business boutique and i really
appreciate what you guys teach
wow thank you that's amazing it's made a
huge difference in my life
way to go i'm proud of you
i needed good guidance so that's where
you guys all came in
i feel like your family thank you we are
how can we help today
um my husband and i just had a little
boy he's three months old
he's awesome we i'm thrilled to be a mom
i'm feeling a little overwhelmed
financially thinking of
all the different things to provide for
him college and
helping him get on the right path also
i just finished the emergency fund but
saving a down payment for a house
putting away money for retirement
putting away money for his college it
all kind of hits at once when you have a
little guy like i hear it all in theory
on your show but now it's for real
and um i'm just wondering some guidance
yeah
so how much you paid off a hundred and
how much debt
a hundred eleven thousand yeah when you
started that
debt snowball that was that tall
that felt unattainable didn't it
it sure did and then as you chipped away
at it
you started going i think i got this and
as the snowball got bigger and bigger
and bigger and you were reaching towards
the end of it you were like
oh now i see it i got it right
remember those emotions yep exact same
thing is going to happen here
exact same thing is going to happen here
you finish your emergency fund
and you're going to start saving for
retirement or a house whichever you want
to do
if you want to do baby step 3b as you
know you've listened to the theory you
said
you can stop everything and save up a
down payment or you can while you're
doing your
15 or some portion towards retirement up
to 15
you start saving for the down payment on
your house but as you know
and you know the story heather you go
baby steps four five and six at the same
time
once you start doing them you start
doing a little bit towards junior
make sure you're putting your 15 away
and you as you guys make more and more
money you'll put more towards junior and
junior is going to be
just fine because you got a really smart
mom and heather i just want to encourage
you
you're you're doing great and you're
okay like you are
this is so new and heather i remember
those feelings i remember someone
telling me when i was pregnant with my
first
son carter that when you have a child it
feels like your your heart is walking
around outside your body it feels so
vulnerable you feel like the weight of
the world on your shoulders this whole
new level of responsibility
that is unlike anything you've ever felt
before and that's that's a little bit of
what you're feeling
and and i just want to encourage you
you're doing
great and you are okay and part of it is
i'm just gonna go on a limb here and say
part of this is the fact that
you're three months out like i remember
i remember one time when i was reading
to carter he was maybe two months old
and i'm reading this book and dave
seriously i just start
crying imagining him going to college
and he's like three months old you've
got a lot of hormones heather you got a
lot of feelings
it's just life is overwhelming right now
you're not getting any sleep
so i just want to say hey you're okay
you're okay you're doing a great job
and you're going to continue to do a
great job and you're going to take care
of that baby
you're doing awesome just like when you
started that snowball when he is six
you're gonna look back and go wow we got
this we have this retirement thing going
we got this
college thing going we almost got the
house paid off and we're going to be in
great shape and you're going to feel
exactly the same way as accomplished as
you feel right now about debt you're
going to feel that way
about his college fund and all these
other things you're worrying about
christy's right you got this
you're doing a good job this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
open phones this hour christy wright
ramsey
personality is my co-host today we're
taking your calls at
with us in 825-5225 wisconsin hi phillip
welcome to the dave ramsey show
can you hear me absolutely what's up
hey dave had to pull over i can't
believe i'm talking to you this is
awesome
um so a little uh back story
um my parents recently approached me
with a possible living situation
uh they want to move up north but they
don't want to sell their house
so they had offered uh my wife and i to
possibly rent from them now i have a
home of my own i still owe
approximately 180 000 on it
i'm wondering if i should sell that or
not um
in the coming year uh what are your what
are your thoughts
what's it worth it's uh worth about
2 30. i'm just wrapping up baby step 2
right now
i got about 5 000 left i think what
scares me is not building equity
um renting for my parents i rented
before and i hated it but the home they
have is beautiful
yeah um yeah that's great but
you're married right i am married yes
sir how many kids you got
no kids i'm 24. okay
all right what do you make a year what's
your household income uh 120.
if this wasn't your parents you wouldn't
even be considering this
yeah yeah i guess you're right you
wouldn't be driving down the road and go
i'm gonna sell my house and rent one
yeah that wouldn't have happened would
it
no i mean you got a nice house my other
thought was i keep my house
and i would rent it out i see this money
um you know chiseling at this debt and
now i want to do it with my mortgage you
know yeah
but i think this is a distraction
you don't need a house you have a house
and you don't need to be a renter you
own a home
and you don't need to sell your home
because you're not in financial trouble
you make plenty of money to pay for this
house you were hitting all your
financial goals
everything's working and also we're
making a hard left on two wheels
i don't see why you would do this
what do you i don't know what you're
gaining by doing this i mean you're not
you're not gaining big traction it's not
like it's going to
throw you forward in your financial
goals uh
it's it's let me actually ask that why
why were you considering it to help your
parents because their house is nicer
like what was going through your head as
like a possibility
a little a little bit of that yeah their
house is very nice
um my wife and i are uh potentially
thinking of starting a family
the schools are really nice in that uh
area and
um yeah the home is beautiful i really
like the home i can never afford that
home right now
right if i would just buy it outright i
think my dad owes
80 000 left on it a very modest mortgage
might basically be be covering his
expenses
um well well he would move up north
okay you're in milwaukee what is north
of milwaukee
oh my gosh okay
i'm from the south so that's funny to me
okay um anyway
uh all right uh
you know i i don't think this serves you
and your family
i think you guys sticking with your plan
serves you and your family better
10 years from now what will have been
the right decision
and i think 10 years from now you will
probably sold this house and moved
to a different school system you'll be
making a lot more money oh by then you
would have a 10 year old in school
now you don't even have a child and you
can't really start thinking about school
systems like eight years before you need
one you don't need to worry about that
today
[Music]
your home in your current situation is
going to go up in value
you're going to pay it down uh you're
you're on track
i i i i think you're going backwards to
sell your house and become a renter i
don't i wouldn't do it
yeah it sounds like a short-term play
that doesn't make any sense
versus a long-term play that makes a
whole lot of sense and and
i think you're just getting distracted
just like dave said i think you're
getting distracted by the fact that it's
your parents and their house is nice if
they weren't your parents
you wouldn't even be considering
something like this and so they
approached you with an opportunity
and it's just it's just not what is in
the right path for you
it doesn't it doesn't make sense for
what you're trying to do and what you
need to do
right now yeah that's hey thanks for the
call you're doing good
yeah steven is in los angeles hi stephen
welcome to the dave ramsey show
all right thank you for taking my call
yeah it's exciting to be able to
uh talk to you you too um i was
listening to you
yesterday and you're talking about whole
life insurance and so i got motivated
and i went ahead and
signed up for a term life program and i
have a whole life
insurance policy that i'm wanting to
get rid of it's got a cash value of
about thirty six thousand dollars
um in it do i just go ahead and
cancel that policy and then they send me
a check
and then you know i've already been
approved for my
current uh 20-year term
how do i go about kind of maneuvering
through this
i would wait till you have the term
policy in your hand
uh you've been approved the
application's been approved but the
policy has not been delivered i want the
policy in your hand
uh and then yes you just simply cancel
it you can send them a note
you can send them a letter you can get
jump on most places have online ability
to cancel now
and that kind of stuff but just enter in
to cash it out
uh they're going to fight you because
they don't like
to cash these things out they like
taking your money
and um so one of the things they're
going to come at you with is
that you're going to have taxes and
there's a very high likelihood you're
not going to have taxes i'll go ahead
and answer that question before it comes
up
okay and here's the reason your basis
for taxes meaning anything over what
your basis is what you pay taxes on
on a whole life policy is the total of
all the premiums you've paid in
in 90 of the cases you pay in more
premiums than you will ever get out
and so my guess is is that if you add up
all the premiums you've ever paid it's
far in excess of 36 000 does that sound
accurate to you
yeah in terms of what i just went
through and did some quick math with my
monthlies i've been paying over the
years and it does
add up yeah it's more if it's more than
36 000 you will have no taxes because
your basis
then would be higher than 36 000 so
you're actually taking a loss
which you cannot claim on your taxes
because of the way these stinking things
are
structured but anyway at least you're
not going to have any taxes so if they
come at you and go oh you don't want to
cash it out you may have taxes capital
gains could hit you
you're not you have to worry about it
because you're not making any money
you're losing money
and all we're doing now stopping the
loss by getting rid of it but
i would wait until you have term life
policy in your hand
uh you want to you want to do a solid
exchange you don't want to drop one
and three days before you get your
policy and then have a car wreck and
wear something weird like that well
because it's a couple weeks i mean it's
a few weeks you gotta have your physical
and you i mean
he said he's been the application's been
approved as what he said so it may be
forthcoming but
either way just wait do you have the
little policy in your hand and then you
will be
considered covered and you know that
you're covered you know that you know
that you know you're covered that's the
big thing so
yeah probably it's not going to be long
but if it's just made application and
they're going to go through a physical
and everything else
with covet it may take a while so some
of these app processes have slowed
way down way down
so hey guys uh inviting you to christy
wright's
new bible study she's doing
you make it sound so official it is
officially going live on instagram
well i mean when you do stuff on
instagram it's pretty official i'm just
saying
and so uh a lot of people follow christy
right on instagram
so living true 40 days to get back
to you the 40 day devotional she's going
to be covering the devotional time uh
in the mornings is it every morning or
once a week once every 10 days i kick
off a new section
it's at christy b wright oh at christy b
wright
um once every 10 days so you did this
morning so 10 days from now that's right
we'll do a new section
and the devotional bestseller is called
living true getting back to you
and you do not want to miss out on this
it's good stuff
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five laura is with us in spokane
washington hi lara how are you
hi i'm well happy new year thank you for
taking my call
sure happy new year to you what's up
so um i first have to say that we're me
and my husband are in our current
financial situation about due to your
steps but kind of through my dad
um my dad always preached your advice
he was always my go-to person but he's
recently passed away so i'm hoping that
papa dave can bless or advise
what next steps to do okay um
and he's up in heaven just smiling right
now that i even got a hold of you so um
it's an honor thank you well thank you
i'm honored
but my husband and i were in our early
30s
and we're wondering what we should do
with a settlement check
um we'll be getting one and then our
minor children will be getting
another one we're on baby step six
our household income is 190 um we're
already putting 16
into our retirement and 150
per month per child and a 539.
and so what we were really going to
focus on these next four years
um is paying our mortgage off yep
do we do right do we throw
the settlement check for us at the
mortgage or invest it
what's the nature of the settlement
where did it come from
uh it's a personal injury
is everyone fully healed
no okay um
are you gonna need some of it for
medical
um i think we'll be okay with our income
because we've been able to do it without
so far
so like something like a car wreck
situation something like a car wreck
yeah okay yeah but how many people were
injured
um two so um
so a minor child and one of you
yes okay so the minor child we want to
put in a trust
and invest we just don't know kind of
how to do that
how much is uh it
000 yeah
for ours yeah do they for each
um she'll be getting 50. okay
all right uh but the medical care
that remains you guys plan to cash flow
correct and you without any doubt
there's no question you're going to do
that so this
you're considering this money quote free
and clear of the
tragedy correct
okay um but i i
i'm kind of mad at the check just
because
the whole events that have happened oh
sure
so i don't really know i don't know what
um i don't have emotional attachment to
it because we've always earned our money
yeah so that's okay that's okay i
understand i mean but it's just a
it's just a mess i mean people got hurt
and obviously it was yeah
yeah it's been really hard it's been
hardest um
with watching our child suffer has been
the hardest part
um so i think just ongoing counseling is
going to be
the main thing and um we'll be able to
cashflow that with our income
um but we do well in your case yes i
would throw it at the mortgage it's a
no-brainer any money we get goes on the
applied baby step
okay in the case of the child the money
is in the child's name
um it's it's a lot of money in one way
but
with the your financial situation it's
really not a lot of money it's okay i
mean
it's um you can put it into a trust um
and that would uh allow you to manage it
further
up into their adulthood if you wanted to
uh
and if you put it just into their name
that is called an atma utma
and that's simply opening a mutual fund
in a kid's name
okay and um
the uh and you would name yourself as a
custodian
and you can choose what to do with the
money and move it around it's all but
it's all for the benefit of the child
obviously a uniform transfer to minors
act which is actually if you open a
child's bank account that's the same
thing
it's done under that exact same piece of
law okay because
you cannot own a bank account or
contract for anything until you're
18 years old and so if a seven-year-old
has a bank account they really don't
it's really in the seven-year-old's name
but it has a it has mom and dad as the
custodian
on the account and the same thing is
true of a mutual fund it's how we used
to do before 529s
and esa's is how we used to do college
funds uh back in the day it's how my
kids
college funds were structured because
that was before those things opened up
so
anyway you can just put in a mutual fund
the downside of that
is that it will uh be a hundred percent
available to the child at 21.
it's their money okay and you're no
longer in control so you're going to
have to
train them that this money is there and
it is a responsibility they didn't hit
the lottery
absolutely and if you want to do that
that's how i did my kids that's fine
if you're because of the counseling is
going on here and the tragedy and that's
kind of stuff if you're more worried
about that
you want to put it into a trust it's
probably going to cost you more taxes
and a trust
than it will in an utmod oh
okay one time yeah probably but i mean
you'd have to see your tax got to be
sure but
a lot of the way depending on how this
trust is structured you can get into a
thing where the trust is paying
ordinary income on that and
the uh utma could grow on a capital
gains basis
and so you may have less taxes with the
utma than you would with the trust
but you lose control at 21. technically
speaking
now we told our kids the money was there
good luck finding it if you're a cocaine
addict we will steal it from you so
uh to protect you from you but um but
we're those kinds of parents
and so uh uh that's what we have done
and but it worked out our kids we
started talking to them about hey you've
got this money
uh that's for your college and
whatever's left over after college
you'll have it
and so it was it was an opportunity for
us to have a teachable moment teaching
them
when they start to be 10 12 years old
about you know they start to do
multiplication you can teach them about
mutual funds
and it gives you a opportunity i mean
christie you're already talking with
your little ones and they're little and
rachel's already teaching her little
ones the basics on money
and you look for things in the rhythm of
life yeah
to have an opportunity to teach them
yeah and it's some simple stuff too i
mean carter's five years old now but
since he was even three
i trained him i said carter where does
money come from he says work work
i was like that's right bud he's like i
need some i want to go buy this i was
like great go to work what do you want
to clean
i need help well and that would be laura
that'd be you just continuing your dad's
legacy
obviously he did that with you he taught
you about it and so you guys are making
a ton of money
you've been very responsible with money
you're down to baby step six you don't
have any debt but your house you're
investing you've got kids colleges going
you've got everything rolling and that's
that's that's your dad's legacy he
taught you
uh how to do that and um way to go
that's very very cool
and now you're gonna get to pass that on
to your child
uh with this money and you know it'll be
part of the uh
emotional and spiritual healing of this
uh thing you guys have gone through
to see the money as a blessing
instead of seeing it as a reminder as a
i don't know a payoff or something you
know as a
it doesn't need to be emotionally
associated with a bad thing we can
change that if we choose to and the
discussion and the narrative of how we
how we deal with the teaching about it
but either way you got to do that
whether it's a trust or
whether it's a um just in an utmod but
uh i i probably as far as that part goes
i probably just sit down with your smart
investor pro and talk that through with
them they can probably give you some
advice about the taxes
that's more accurate than mine i'm not
very good at
taxes i don't do my own so never trust
dave's tax advice it sucks there's about
five things i know about taxes and i'm
100 right on those and the rest of them
i don't know i almost made a mistake on
my stuff this week
and i stopped and had the accountant
look at it and he went no
and i went oh see there it is dadgummit
okay
there's a weird little thing though
anyway hey i'm sorry you guys went
through this and i'm
glad you got the blessing the financial
blessing from having gone through the
hard time that puts us hour today ramsey
showing the books our thanks to james
childs and kelly daniel in the booth
i am dave ramsey your host and we will
be back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice christy
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five in mcallen texas starts off
this hour
hi mary how are you hi dave how are you
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up um okay so
i hopefully got willing about next month
i should get
a baby step three done six months of
expenses
for emergency fund my question is
because my six months of expenses is
basically the same as what's left to pay
off on the mortgage
should i use that fund to pay off the
mortgage
early and then build up my six month
expenses
all over again because with that
mortgage bill gone
it'll be a lot easier to build up six
months expenses
unless you had an emergency in the
meantime
right so i have one month emergency
expenses and cash
here in my home but the rest of it is
the six months
other things so technically i have i'll
have seven months okay well i wouldn't
have seven i would have
six as a max uh you can have anywhere in
the range of three to six but i would
not go
go below three paying off your home is
exciting but it is not an emergency
okay and i don't want you to have a paid
for home
and have an emergency and no money
okay i agree so let's just take a little
bit more time
and get the house paid off but if you
want to dial it down to three months and
you're comfortable with that
from six or seven then use that four
towards the idea then yeah that could
move you forward i'd be okay with that
but i wouldn't go below three months
emergency fund
the baby steps are in that order for the
reason that
being debt-free other than your home
having your emergency fund in place
that those are foundational things to
create stability in your life when
crap happens like pandemics you know
this is your fault you get people so
excited they just want to pay it off so
fast i have had this call
every time i'm on the show with you can
i use
this money this savings whatever to pay
off my home early they go to these
extremes
it's because you get them so motivated
and you get them so worked up
and then they're just ready to do all
the steps all at one time this is your
fault
it is my fault so i get the opportunity
to clarify what i really meant
but yeah but yeah it's awesome that
she's excited though
that's awesome and here's the thing the
truth is
if there if i was sitting in that
situation that's the exact question i'd
be asking
because i'd want to be done yeah i want
to go i want to run and see the finish
line i want to run through that tape on
the finish line i want to finish i want
my time to be over
i want to be done i want to move on to
the next thing
check that box you know have
accomplished that goal
and and i am a uh rachel talks about in
our new book uh know yourself know your
money
the scarcity people and the abundance
people mm-hmm uh
scarcity people do not ask this question
yep abundance people ask this question
that's right
because abundance people assume there's
not going to be an emergency that's
right
during the time that you don't have an
emergency right you know i saw rachel
but speaking of i saw rachel put
something on instagram this is a couple
weeks ago and it was a picture of a gas
tank
where it's like half empty and it's like
i need to fill up and then there's
another gas tank
that's on e and it's like i got plenty
of room that is me i run on fumes my
husband's filling up if he's got any
amount of gas
it's so true we just look at this same
amount completely different
isn't that funny it it's uh but that's a
you know and again there's nothing wrong
with being an abundance person there's
nothing wrong with being a scarcity
person but you just always know who's
asking that question
and you don't want to go too far on the
extremes because that's where you find
the toxicity
on any of these uh all these tendencies
that rachel talks about but that
and that's one of them that's a good
spectrum right there to think about when
you're looking at
uh questions like this is is it because
i'm an abundance person
because abundance people like me and you
we think we can out earn our stupidity
oh i told matt the other day i go see
money's just so fluid you just go get
more
and he's like what is this hand motion
what is this what is this what's this
thing like
go get more it goes out then it's like a
chair but it comes in
go get more go get more he's like
you know
he's like who are you i don't even know
who you are right exactly great
but but i love your answer there i want
to go back to that really quickly i'd
love your answer because it doesn't have
to be
all or nothing she's got seven months of
emergency fund she can have three months
emergency
fund to take take four months worth put
it towards the mortgage and she's well
on you know she's making
almost there that's almost there if six
months does it four months is coming
pretty close that's right
so knock her out get her done william is
with us in jackson mississippi
hi william welcome to the dave ramsey
show hey dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up um
so i'm planning on graduating from
college in the next
uh this time next year actually
congratulations i'll be debt free from
student loans
wow i won't have a home and i have a
full job
full-time job that's lined up for this
time next year
starting at about 75 000 a year with
401k options and
benefits good my question is
what should i do when looking for
getting a new house or starting
look for my first home
currently i want to live outside the
city limits because the inner city texas
where i live
is tremendously larger than it would be
in outside the city limits so what do
you suggest i should do for my first
house
okay well you've established one thing
you want you know what you want you want
to be outside the city
um the first thing i would tell you is
you don't have to be in a hurry
um i'm okay if you wait a year or two
i don't want you to be a renter your
whole life but you are not being
like crazy man or you're not stupid or
something by not buying a house
immediately
because the first couple years out of
college is when is one of the most
transitional times of most people's
lives
new jobs new relationships all kinds of
things going on
and a home is a very permanent
type decision it's something that's not
easy to undo you can buy a car and get
rid of a car pretty easy about
you know by the end of the week right
but a house you you buy it you're gonna
you know it takes a little while to get
rid of that thing if you've got the
wrong one or something
and so um you know first thing i would
do is not buy for the first six months
out of school
maybe the first year out of school um
and maybe even more is okay but at least
six months between six months and a year
is fine
somewhere in there the second thing then
is when you get ready to buy a home
take your time in searching and really
researching
it's a large purchase and uh when we
teach
business people and leadership decision
making skills
one of the things we teach them is he
with the most
options and the most information
wins the negotiation and wins a good
decision
if you look at two houses and you pick
one out that's like going on a
date with a girl two times and getting
married
okay and so you know you don't want to
do that we want to take our time
get to know this area look at several
properties
i'm looking at a second home situation
right now and i probably looked at
60 properties in that area because i
enjoy it i'm a real estate guy but
i look at a lot of properties i learned
their square foot prices i learned the
you know where the uh the popular side
of the tracks is
and the popular side of those tracks is
and down into the cul-de-sacs and what's
the differences
and i want to learn and learn and learn
and learn to learn learn learn and learn
learn and then you'll make a better
[Music]
decision
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices and they make it
simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here
ezra is with us in chicago hi ezra how
are you
i'm doing all right i can't complain
considering how the years been
uh last year so it's been
pretty i would say 2020 was a year
fourth year of my life
um made some pretty poor financial
decisions
and having to pay for those now and just
um looking for the best way to
to get out of that cool i understand
i've been there myself brother
how can we help um so
about 80k in debt um
making currently about
27 to 3 000 a month just
recently was promoted to um area manager
so i'll be starting that
in april and that pays very nicely it
will pay
i'll get a startup bonus um a moving
bonus as well so i'll be making about
50 i think about 55 60k
um plus the startup bonuses
um but definitely looking to
get out of um yeah just get out of debt
because i've actually never been that
before in my life so this is a whole new
experience for me
what kind of that is and i'm still
it is some of it i mean it's kind of
like all the work is with 2020
um i apply for a
for a number of things such as um
from rent to utilities
and um i applied for
just different aid and some of it and
actually told it was supposed to be
granted but for whatever it will deny
i bought a car and
that i would end up returning that
because that was just
very it was not a wise decision
looking back because so what is the 80
000 break it down for me what do you owe
80 000 to
okay so for the car
i owe about 20. and that's a repo fee
that's the deficit on the repo okay
right i turned it in
got it it's a voluntary repossession so
you owe 20 000 deficit you lost 20 000
on the transaction
so what's the next thing okay so the
next thing
so i have about 10 grand student loan
and then i have um
about 8 grand in
in housing so i was actually supposed to
be approved for
um that amount uh a lot during 2020
and so i wasn't worried about it you
mean unpaid rent bad rent on a place you
used to live
right at a place i used to live okay so
you
have got a landlord you owe an old
landlord you owe a grant to
right which was they were surprised too
because they're like
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
that's part of your screw up you believe
the crap
out of the government okay so that's
only 38 what's the rest of this
okay so then um i have
for unemployment they want to
collect um what they what they helped me
with
during um you know what they helped me
with during
2020 it was i feel like it was their
mistake
and i've tried argument with them um
they're just like to set up a payment
plan
do you have to pay so you took you got
more unemployment than you were due
according to them yeah how much
uh seven grand total okay what's the
rest of this
okay so then um about 54. let me see
off the other 13 and credit cards
and um and actually
that that's it that's 58 that's not 80.
okay you're right i sort of calculated
that
okay good that's good news that's a good
miscalculation we've already got we've
already gotten rid of a bunch of debt
well done this call is going great
all right so the old landlord and the
unemployment
and the car repo and for that matter
even the student loan do not require
payments today you can put the student
loan on hardship deferral
tell the rest of them uh you're already
in default these are things you didn't
pay that you should have paid or
shouldn't have ever taken out
and so you're not paying payments on any
of those things right now
that leaves you only with credit card
debt
okay for right now first and so
chop up all your credit cards we're
gonna get you on a budget we're gonna
tear into these credit cards as fast as
we can
and listen you get no life because last
year you made a mess and this year
you got no life because you're gonna be
doing nothing but working
all the time six jobs you're not gonna
go out to eat unless you're working in a
restaurant
you are not gonna go on vacation for
dadgum sure you are broke and deeply in
debt
you need to get in attack mode do you
agree
i agree 80 hours a week six jobs
delivering pizzas uber eats i don't care
what you're doing cutting grass
blowing leaves i don't care what you're
doing man you're gonna make some money
and you're gonna take your regular job
too
and you're going to work all the time no
partying
none allowed i don't even care if you
have a social life at all i just want
you to work
for one year and you can clean this
whole freaking mess up in
one year but at the end of the year
you're going to be really tired
and you're gonna be free is that okay
yeah that's okay with me you gotta go
bananas okay so
then what we're gonna do is we're gonna
go ahead and knock these credit cards
out list them smallest to largest pay
minimum payments on all of them except
the smallest one
put every dollar you can squeeze out of
your budget on that smallest one then
every dollar on the next one until it's
gone then every dollar on the next one
so it's gone when all the credit cards
are gone
then we're going to take these other
debts and list them smallest to largest
and begin to work your way through them
by the way you're going to pay off that
13 000
of credit cards in about two months
okay because you're not gonna do nothing
else and you're gonna be working a lot
so the current income that you have is
gonna almost
double yeah and you're going to throw it
all
all every dollar you're going to eat and
keep your lights on
and take a shower and go back to work
and that's all you're going to do until
you get this mess cleaned up and if you
do that dude i can get you through this
in 12 months
but you're going to have to be with it
man i mean you're playing for the super
bowl there's no let up there's
no it's game on you're going to leave it
all on the field okay
yeah absolutely so you knock those
credit cards out you're going to reach
over and knock that landlord out pretty
quick then that unemployment then we'll
reach over and
uh we start the student loans up and by
the way i want you to save up about
5 000 when you get down in that stuff
and offer that
car five thousand dollars settlement on
that repo
you can settle those repo for about a
quarter on the dollar wow
okay wow i didn't know that yeah so we
just got rid of another 15 grand in that
when you get down there
but let them sit over there and cook a
little while while you work on the rest
of this
and don't call them until you've got the
five grand saved and say
and don't don't tell them you have a
dime more than that i got five thousand
dollars that's all i've got
if you'll take that i can make this go
away today if you won't take that i
can't do anything i'll just have to wait
don't make payments on that repo
okay settle it in a lump sum with a
settlement and an argument
okay they're used to losing money on
repos it's why they don't like them
and so and uh then you've learned your
lesson right
you're not gonna do this kind of stuff
anymore learn my lesson okay there's two
lessons in your there's two lessons in
your in your story from it from me if
i'm reading your tea leaves
lesson number one is we don't buy cars
unless we pay cash period as a matter of
fact we don't buy anything
unless we pay cash for the rest of your
life if this is the worst mistakes you
ever make in your life you're going to
be a multi-millionaire
okay if you learn from them but if you
go back and make the same stupid mistake
again
then you're going to be what's called
normal people that say the same
dead gum thing over and over again and
can't figure out why they're broke
so don't be that guy okay the second
lesson is
you were hoping that someone was coming
to help you
you thought the lone ranger was coming
you thought the calvary was coming
and you thought unemployment was a gift
and you thought the landlord was going
to get a free gift from the government
and you thought and and none of it
worked when you wait on the government
to fix your life
your life sucks people you cannot wait
on washington to fix your life or anyone
in government
you have to take control of it these are
the two lessons from your story ezra
hold on i'm going to put you on hold and
send you a copy of the total money
makeover to show you how to do this
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really like the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show chrissy
wright ramsey personality
is my co-host today sean
is with us in chicago sean i see on my
screen you're debt free congratulations
yes sir thank you dave well done how
much did you pay off
uh 32 124
and about 27 months very good how long
did this
you said 27 months and what was your
range of income during that time
uh i float right around 90 000. i'm in
sales so i peek a little below that a
little above that sometimes
gotcha well well done well done okay
what kind of debt was the 32 000
oh it was all the normal stuff uh
unfortunately i had reached the stage of
insanity
and repeated uh yeah repeated this a few
times many more times than i care to
admit but um
this is the final time and i put uh you
know it was the
straw that broke the camel's back so it
was a car
i had a couple of credit cards that went
to
settlements i had a couple of
family loans i had some medical debt
that came up for some minor surgery that
i had
so yeah it was all over the board
okay wow well good for you man so what
started all this 27 months ago because
you're a man on a mission
yeah i had a job where i had a company
car
and because of some of the past history
with my money it was the only car that i
had
so when i left that job i needed a car
and unfortunately i
went out and financed one which was the
quote-unquote normal thing to do
but thankfully this time i went out and
got a used one at least
and um the bank charged me
17.24 interest on the car
and uh for me uh that was
and i've had it moment and i started to
think about
my daughter and the amount of times that
i've gone through this
and this this was it for me so um
august 4th 2018 uh
i wrote uh down my money makeover plan
after reading your total money makeover
book
and so i want to thank you for the the
process and the wisdom and
the guidance that you've given me to
help me change my life
really well thank you you did it i'm so
proud of you very well done sir
very well done how's it feel now that
you're free for the last time
well it feels amazing it's uh it's i
feel kind of like uh
the wave was crushing me before and
maybe i'm on top of the wave now but i
i guess i'm still not used to not having
any debt i mean i
just finished paying it off in november
uh so i'm ready
i'm ready for the wave to uh to help me
build that fully funded emergency fund
and
so i'm still a little anxious but i'm
glad it's done yeah
and baby step two's behind me you've
been so intense it feels a little bit
surreal when you get the other side of
it
it feels it feels weird i mean
unfortunately dave i mean i'm 48
my whole life i've been terrible with
money
and it was a lot of a lot of it was
around cars
you know just being done with cars and
buying new cars and then rolling the
you know then in the next cars and
for whatever reason just throughout my
life it hasn't been
my strong point but it is now uh my
daughter
so 16 in may she's probably sick of
hearing me
talk about it but you know i just i am
so thankful for all the free
information that the podcast provides
and the every dollar plus
app is amazing i've never budgeted
before in my life until i started using
every dollar
um and now i do it every month wow
that's awesome just uh yeah it's just
part of my
part of my routine it's a total a
totally different
way of thinking and it's it's changed my
life honest to gosh
and now you get to keep your money sean
when you get paid you get to keep your
money you're not sending it backwards to
all these bills
and all your hard work you actually get
to keep it and like you said work on
this
baby step three but man what an awesome
moment where you get to let that sink in
that your money
is yours you get to keep it so what do
you tell people the secret to getting
out of debt is because you have been
very successful yes for me
you know this program has opened my mind
my heart
to a lot of different things i had to
submit to a new way of doing things
and really approve and plan
you know so for me that was the biggest
thing was just kind of letting go
i i um i have a side hustle where i
install wireless security cameras and
i'll just give you a quick
example of how my mindset has changed at
first i was davish
so i still had a couple of credit cards
and i went out and bought some cameras
that were on sale because they were 25
off and i thought that'll be great for
my inventory but i bought them on a
credit card
and they sat on my dining room table and
i just said to myself i wouldn't have
done that
had had i not had the credit cards you
know because i didn't have the cash to
purchase them
so i took them back and that day i
shredded the credit cards
there you go closing your towels ding
ding
it's amazing it's amazing how you make
decisions differently when you take
debt off the table when it's not an
option just like you said sean just like
you did
that's that's powerful dude and the most
gratifying piece dave is that i changed
my family tree
yeah amen so what's your daughter's name
uh it's ashlynn ashlyn a-s-h-l-y-n-n
okay so is she there to scream with you
she is she's
all right very good well we've got a
copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires and um
you're definitely going to be one that's
the next chapter in your story my
brother i'm proud of you very very well
done
all right sean and ashlynn 32
000 paid off in 27 months making 90 000
changed forever count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream
three two one debt-free
[Music]
love it love it love it congratulations
that's amazing
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mess up you measure them wrong
you pick the wrong
color it's ugly they will remake your
blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run all the
time
you save even more always use the promo
code
ramsey today's question comes from al in
new york
my wife and i are debt free and have 200
000 between stocks and 401k
she's a real estate agent and i'm a
utility worker in new york city over the
last year
i took my online fitness coaching
business off the ground
and its monthly income is sometimes
higher than my regular job
we have a paid off house on the greek
athens riviera and my wife and i
are considering moving there she is
greek and would work in real estate
there
should i quit my job and work on the
business remotely
how do i get over the fear of losing
security benefits in a guaranteed
paycheck
as well as fear of failure that's a lot
that's a lot going on there david yeah
there's a lot happening there
well the problem is you are not uh
changing one thing you're changing
everything everything i mean she does
not have a real estate career there
she'd have to start from scratch you do
not have a
uh fitness career there you'd be
starting from scratch
except what you can do remotely and so
you're not giving up
um one job you're giving up three
yeah when you leave and starting fresh
on
things you know about but uh what i
would consider is
i would want to have some money saved uh
to get you through the first six months
uh not the emergency fund in addition to
that i'd want to have a nest egg of some
kind
uh i don't mind you giving up your
secure job as long as you're moving to
something where you
have a proven track record of making
money and you don't in greece
right right and what's interesting is i
love this last question how do i get
over the fear
of losing security benefits and a
guaranteed paycheck as well as the fear
of failure
you know dave one of the questions i get
all the time and i know you've heard me
talk about this
is how do i know is it fear or wisdom if
you've got some legitimate concerns and
a basis for them that's wisdom
that's not fear you should just push
into and do it scared this is like no
let's
pay attention and do this smart yeah
um if you had the income from real
estate
and the fitness career going that was
equal to what it is in the states
it wouldn't be it'd be it would be
irrational fear
right this is rational fear right i'm
afraid reading your story
i i mean i want you to have a lot more
of these holes plugged before you do
this move
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today romans 5 3 and 4
more than that we rejoice
in our sufferings knowing that suffering
produces endurance and endurance
produces character and character
produces hope winston churchill said
there is no time for ease and comfort
it is time to dare
and endure this is no time
for ease and comfort it is time to
dare and endure tia
is with us in roswell georgia hi tia
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey thank you for taking my call and i
respect both of your opinions so much so
thank you
thank you um i'm trying to decide if i'm
crazy for thinking about expanding the
business right now with everything
that's going on with covid so i'm a
reflexologist
and right now i rent a room inside an
office space to
work out of and i'm paying 250 a month
but in april the lease will be up there
the lady that i'm reading from is not
renewing another five year lease
so i feel like it's an opportunity for
me to grow and expand
and i'm looking at um getting a whole
office suite
that has well the one i was looking at
has seven offices because it's
a better deal than the ones that only
have like three or four offices
and then renting out the other rooms as
i rent the room now
because normally you can rent a room for
about four or five hundred dollars but
if with everything that's going on with
covet i don't know if that's just crazy
or if it is actually a good time to grow
well it's not really growing your
business you're getting in the sub
leasing business yeah
yeah yes but i do want to become a
health coach
eventually and then i would have another
office as well because with seven
offices
i could rent if i rented five of them
for four or five hundred dollars that
would more than cover
the rent yeah but now you're in the real
estate business why don't you just stay
in your business and rent two offices
yeah yeah i don't there aren't two
offices available
and the problem is if i just rent a room
then i'm going to be paying 500 per full
time
in in the area that i'm working yeah but
if any of those other rooms are empty
out of those seven you're going to be
paying 900
or they're yeah they don't pay their
rent well
it's just 1800 for the rent for
that offer i know but if they're all
empty or not paying because
because their businesses didn't operate
while yours did you now have eighteen
hundred dollars worth of rent because
you got in the real estate business
it's a risk and that's why i'm wondering
if it's crazy or not
i don't know if it's crazy but i just
think you're i think you're confusing it
with your actual business
what you want to do is if you want to
grow your business you can grow your
business and it has nothing to do with
you renting out other offices to other
businesses well
i would like to grow in that way as well
because i would like to have a wellness
center at some point and the lady that i
rent from now i was asking her about it
and how it's worked for her
and she said in the 10 years that she's
been in roswell she's never had to pay
her rent because
people that rent rooms from her more
than cover it
because she's a massage therapist so i'd
be you know
that could be part of it here's what i
would say
in this in this whole renting out of the
room's idea and i want dave jump in he's
definitely the real estate expert
but let's just say that you do want to
have this additional space you find a
space and
and something other than this one or
seven options something in between like
dave and i are talking about
and you find a place that has two to
three rooms that you can afford all
three rooms if all three rooms are
not rented out and then anybody you get
to rent rooms two and three is bonus
money for you
but you're not going to put yourself in
a position to hope and pray and wish
that these other rooms are rented out
exactly exactly you're gonna you're
gonna be sitting there more fretting
about rentals than you are fretting
about running your business it's gonna
suck the joy out of your business yeah
yeah you need to have a a total rent
that if nobody is there but you that
does not put you out of business
1800 puts you out of business and uh
you're going from 250
now to 500 for one or two
um or to 1800 i mean if you want if you
want to go on up to
uh you know 700 or a thousand or
something and have
four rooms or something like that that's
fine but i i think that you're taking on
too much here
and i think you're going to get
distracted you need to focus on being a
reflexologist not a real estate
broker yeah and when you're when you're
spending all your time and your energy
focusing on this real estate stuff that
you don't know anything about by the way
this is something you have to
there's a learning curve to this it's
taking away
from you potentially growing and
expanding to this health studio you're
talking about wanting to add that's
going to take time and energy too you're
trying to do too many things if you have
two or three rooms and you get that
operating successfully and you make some
money
uh and then you go to a different model
and you say okay now i want to build my
wellness center or now i want to rent
out something and create a wellness
center
now you've got to stay you've taken some
baby steps to get there rather than this
leap
uh i'm afraid this is gonna set you back
because i'm afraid it's harder than it
sounds to you
a matter of fact i know it's harder than
it sounds to you to keep to keep these
things full
of people who pay their rent
uh because you know it's a process to
learn to put the right people in a
building
as a landlord and um you know not just
believe everybody that walks up and says
yeah i can pay the rent
tim is with us tim's in lima ohio hi tim
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave it's uh thank you for taking my
call
i i may
i'm a an officer in the united states
army and uh through
the army national guard in indiana and
uh
i just got offered a twenty thousand
dollar retention bonus
uh for three years uh three additional
years of service
and i currently like my two major uh
debts are my student loan which is like
i think fourteen thousand uh nine
or seven hundred dollars and
uh a car which is like twenty eight
thousand dollars
and i was wondering that since we're in
uh the covid
season and interest rates for my student
loan or
at zero and i'm technically in
forbearance even though i'm making
payments
on it uh should i take this 20 000
bonus which will roughly be about 14
after taxes
and put it towards the student loan or
should i put it
towards the car which i'm still accruing
interest in
uh what do you make a year
uh well i'm actually as an officer i
make about twelve thousand eight hundred
dollars and then as
a defense contractor i make uh roughly
around ninety
thousand dollars a year so in the end
i'll come home with about
with overtime about 115 000 yeah
this car is not completely in the crazy
zone but it's close
yeah i know
um well i would pay off your student
loan with your bonus
and then i would either get an attack
mode and get that car paid off in about
18 months
or i'd sell it and move down one of the
two
right but the interest on it doesn't
matter to me what matters to me is is
that you lean into both of these things
and knock them out
one way or another as fast as you
possibly can
i mean of all the things you told me
about your whole life the thing that
doesn't fit in the sentence is this car
thank you for your service by the way
yes i mean your very critical thinking
skills on everything but then you like
lost your mind one day and bought a car
i mean it's like you know the
student loan's not out of hand it's not
a good thing i'm glad you're getting rid
of it
you know the resign bonus is a good idea
you know you're serving your country
thank you
you know you're you're you know you've
got a whole process of thought process
on everything until it came to this car
and it's just like this weird thing
sitting there in the whole sentence
it doesn't fit so i'm okay if you keep
it because it's not more than half your
annual
income and you can pay it off in under
two years but dude i'd get rid of the
debt within a very short period of time
i would lean into it knock it out as
fast as you possibly can
and uh if you're not willing to like
jack up that car and get rid of it in
terms of that then you need to look at
moving down and out of it
it's not something you want to coast
around on you if you're going to keep it
you need to get it paid for
it's like you always saying i love this
quote i quote you all the time you say
you can wander into debt you cannot
wander out you have to get fired up and
do something different or else that
car payment will stay there forever i
mean it will be there forever
sure will that's exactly right well good
show today christy this is fun
thanks for hanging out james childs and
kelly daniel in the booth thank you
great job our producer assistant
producer
i am dave ramsey your host will be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you